attack on titan season 4 is finally
underway
and among all the characters we were
introduced to during the season premiere
only one of them is a new holder of one
of the nine titans
that person is porco galliard who now
possesses the jaw titan
after inheriting it from ymir this video
will explain everything that's different
about poco's draw titan
and we'll also touch on his interesting
backstory before we get into it be sure
to hit that sub button for more attack
on titan videos like this
and let me know in the comments which
topics you'd like to see me cover
during season four okay so poco galliard
is the younger brother of marcel
galliard who is a character we've
briefly seen before
marcel was the original person selected
to be the draws titan
and together with rainer annie and
bertolt marcel travelled to paradise
island
with the intention of taking the
founding titan unfortunately for him
before marcel ever made it to the walls
he was eaten by a random titan
which turned out to be yamir as marcel's
younger brother
poco was also a prime warrior candidate
and he looks set to inherit the armored
titan
in all honesty it really should have
been poco and not
reiner who received this titan but poco
was sabotaged by his brother
so that rhino would be the one to get it
you may think this sounds mean
but in reality marcel was just trying to
protect his brother
as anyone who inherits a titan shifter
can't live
longer than 13 years after receiving it
this is of course due to the curse of
ymir
and the we're talking about the original
ymir not the emir who had the draws
titan
anyway going back to poco as the other
warrior candidates inherited their titan
shifters
poker was the only one left with nothing
and he stayed behind
as his brother and the rest of them went
to the island to retake the founding
titan
in the manga we see flashbacks of poco's
time as a warrior candidate
in which he was shown to think very
little of reiner he describes reiner as
the weakest in the group
and someone who is basically a butt
kisser with no real talent of his own
after this argument he even punched
reiner in the face
and then on a separate occasion he tried
to punch reiner again
after after rhino was chosen as the
armored titan
his hatred for rhino grew even more once
he discovered many years later
that his brother marcel had died to
protect him from this titan
things eventually came full circle
though as ymir would willingly give the
draw titan back to mali
with porco chosen to be the inheritor
this new draw titan is very similar to
how his brothers used to look
but it could not be any more different
to ymir's one to start with
he has hardened skin covering his face
which offers a degree of protection that
yamir's titan never had
this hardened skin is clearly
bulletproof to an extent as we saw
during episode 1
and his claws also appear longer than
hers used to be as well
this is great for crushing things or
ripping them apart and his arms are just
significantly larger than hers used to
be
as you'd expect the draw of the draw
titan is its main appeal
thanks to porco will get a good look
this season at just how powerful this
draw actually is
as he'll crush things that other titans
simply cannot do
additionally the draw titan is the
swiftest of them all
and can maneuver around at great speeds
that can catch other titans off guard
one interesting thing about porco is
that he is currently
unable to see the memories of his
brother despite inheriting the same
titan
he can however see the memories of ymir
and through her eyes he saw how rhino
was pretending to be the big brother to
all the scouts on the island
it kind of made poco think that reiner
was trying to imitate marcel
and to be honest that pretty much was
the case so yeah
poco is basically right in his
assumption anyway guys
that was the new draw titan explained be
sure to drop a like if you haven't
already
and like i said at the beginning let me
know which topics you'd like to see me
cover
in the future until the next one peace
out